presenting a united front
Alexander lukashinka meeting Vladimir
Putin for the first time since he helped
into Mutiny by Wagner mercenaries in
Russia last month Belarus is now hosting
the group's Fighters as part of a deal
with their leader yevgeni bragosian
the Wagner Fighters have become a
concern they're asking to let them go
west I'm asking them why would you do
that and we're quietly keeping tabs on
them they say we just want to you know
go on a trip to Warsaw and geshav jeshab
triggers them because when they fought
in bakmut they knew where the military
hardware was coming from
so they have this feeling that jeshav is
a problem of course I'm keeping them in
central Belarus like we agreed and I
wouldn't want to redeploy them there as
they're in this bad mood
mercenary groups presence in Belarus has
seen EU and NATO member Poland send more
troops to its eastern border Poland's
Former Defense Minister says his country
is prepared Belarus doesn't have an army
to speak of NATO is 20 times more
powerful than Russia they shouldn't
start anything because they'll lose
and back to the war in Ukraine and both
leaders putting kiev's stuttering
counter-offensive in the spotlight
this is a Mindless policy of throwing
unprepared people and mercenaries into
the Hellfire
so there's no counter-offensive
there is one but it has failed it has
failed there are no results
a visit to the naval Cathedral of Saint
Nicholas a symbolic show of Faith two
leaders growing ever closer as the war
in Ukraine grinds on Alex beard Al
Jazeera